hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast does your protein
analysis tool box need to refresh
presented by rich jones PhD we're
excited to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab and
sponsored by beckman coulter life
sciences Beckman culture develops
manufactures and markets products that
will 58 and innovate complex biomedical
testing more than 275,000 ethnic
cultures systems operate in both
diagnostics and life sciences laboratory
on seven continents for over 75 years
our products have been making a
difference in people's lives by
improving the productivity of medical
professionals and scientists supplying
critical information for improving
teaching health and delivering trusted
solutions for research and discovery to
learn more about beckman coulter life
sciences please visit www you or close
lab roots and i'll be your moderator for
today's event this webinar has been
approved for canoeing educational
credits please click on the CTE button
at the bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credit before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen will answer as many questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation also please notice that you
will be viewing the presentation in the
slide window to enlarge the window just
click on the screen icon located on the
lower right finally if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of the presentation window
or use the Q&A button to let us know
that you're having a problem thank you
now I'd like to introduce dr. rich Jones
dr. Jones for the long-standing interest
in the development and application of
automated protein analysis technologies
and workflows for interrogating protein
systems in human biology and
pharmacology
he has more than 20 years of experience
in the field of protein and cell bio
technology as an assistant professor in
the bed made apartment for cancer
research at the University of Chicago
dr. Jones developed micro Western arrays
for studying the responses of cancer
cells to therapeutics and for
understanding chemo therapeutic
resistance mechanisms it was also a
course fellow and founding member of the
Institute for genomics and systems
biology and founder and director of the
University of Chicago micro Western
array protein analysis core facility dr.
Jones's complete bio is found on the lab
roots website please join me in
welcoming dr. Jones I will now turn the
presentation over to him thank you very
much Judy it's a pleasure to be here and
I welcome everyone to my presentation
entitled does your protein analysis tool
box need a refresh so in today's talk I
will be providing a survey of protein
analysis tools I won't be diving too
deeply into each of them but depending
upon the feedback that we get I may
present more deep analysis of specific
areas of protein analysis tools in the
future so the presentation that i will
describe today is a bit of a meshing of
graduate level courses that i put
together while at the university of
chicago and lyle a teaching fellow at
harvard university over the years and
again i welcome your feedback so that we
might go in more detail in the future to
help you all and your in your own work
so in today's presentation I will
provide an overview of protein analysis
methods and I will use the life of the
biotherapeutic as a framework with which
to introduce to discuss these methods
and so for the purposes of today's talk
we're going to follow the life of a
prototypical biotherapeutic from the
stage at which discovery has occurred
biological discovery in in cells and
testing hypotheses onward to the course
of expression and purification of
proteins to further doing binding
analysis and surveying protein
interactions and then onward to
biophysical characterization we won't
talk so much about downstream work in
manufacturing so firstly why our protein
is important this is near and dear to my
heart that's what I've spent most of my
life studying proteins represent the
machines encoded by our genomes and by
all genomes that perform nearly all the
functions of living systems they range
from quite small sizes for insulin and
other types of growth factors and that
they can also be quite big as as an
example of collagen fibers where
proteins assemble into larger higher
molecular weight complexes and again
what is quite important is that they
link our genomes with our health and so
when things go wrong with protein
systems and it's typically a fundamental
root cause of diseases so I described
here the epidermal growth factor system
it's responsible for many types of
cancer including breast cancer which the
her to therapeutic is a target and
non-small cell lung carcinoma for which
the EGF receptor is a target and in this
particular system a growth factor the
epidermal growth factor binds to the
epidermal growth factor receptor many
cases it leads to the heterodimerization
with other partners like herb b2 which
is also known as her to the breast
cancer target this leads the activation
of receptors on cell surface and it
tells them to grow there are a number of
dark homology to so call
proteins that recognize the
modifications on tyrosines subsequently
and it leads to a lot of events
downstream that ultimately caused the
cells to grow and metabolize quicker and
in many cases when we get older these
systems go awry and it leads to cancer
so proteins can undergo extensive
modification if you just start with our
genome that has about 20,000 genes in it
that can be alternatively transcribed
and spliced into different mRNAs which
can then be translated alternatively and
modified alternatively and it gets leads
to high complexity of proteins and it
requires a variety of complex tools to
understand the systems when they're
working and then also to try to
understand how they go wrong so here's
an artistic rendition of the
platelet-derived growth factor receptor
in red binding to the yellow highlighted
platelet-derived growth factor receptor
on the cell surface and you can see a
little antibodies that look like little
v-shaped molecules and this is an
artistic rendition of of the complexity
of types of molecules that we're
studying and trying to understand for
the development of therapeutics so as I
mentioned aberrations and protein
signaling networks lead to diseases on
the Left I depict a cell signaling
network that I studied while I was an
assistant professor at the University of
Chicago and it was subsequently
published in cancer prevention research
where we studied the action of honey bee
hive propolis which is material that
bees used to stitch up their hives and
we used micro Western arrays to
understand the networks that were
impacted by the addition of honeybee
hive propolis or feeding to mice and we
studied
their impacts on tumor cells and when
the tumor cells were growing they would
have activation of a series of signaling
networks that led to their growing more
quickly and detaching from cells and
when we applied honey bee hive propolis
it it more or less turned off their
ability to sense insulin so it shut down
the insulin signaling network so in
therapeutics biotherapeutics where we're
developing molecules often we're trying
to develop neutralizing antibodies to
the ligands that are attaching to growth
factor receptors sometimes we're trying
to prevent there the dimerization of the
receptors themselves or their activation
or their small molecules that are
developed which inhibit the kinase
domains of these growth factor receptors
on their intracellular surface sometimes
there are inhibitors designed to prevent
the heterodimerization partners such as
her to her three with the epidermal
growth factor receptors so as I've
approached the study of protein systems
I show here a graph that describes the
understanding of individual proteins and
this is typically performed with
biochemistry and biophysics methods
where individual proteins are expressed
purified and subjected to a variety of
tests to understand and quite detail the
individual molecular events that lead to
protein activation at the other end of
the spectrum we have proteomic tools to
understand whole proteomes in the middle
area that I've spent a lot of work
developing tools i call protein omics
and this is helpful for understanding of
biological processes where we want to
understand lots of proteins typically on
the order of a hundred in order to focus
our efforts on understanding biological
processes as best we
can without diving too deeply into
individual proteins so this a threat
brings up an important point which is
the scale at which you are conducting
your research and it's important to when
you're going into a trying to solve a
biological problem to understand at what
scale on the left I show individual
pipettes and then multi-channel pipettes
and as we get farther to the right you
start to have the need for automation to
do multi-channel pipettes and
multi-channel liquid handling in order
not only to speed up the process but
more importantly to reduce the
variability associated with the results
because as you begin collecting hundreds
of data points there are thousands of
data points it's quite critical to
reduce the variability so that you can
be able to compare data across time and
across individual experiments so here I
provide an overview of the life of a
prototype there biotherapeutic and it's
this overview that will serve as the
foundation for the top today I start off
with target and pathway discovery and
the tools associated therewith and next
the protein expression purification
optimization phase then I'll discuss the
screening of proteins for binding
targets or modulators protein targets
and finally I will discuss a series of
methods associated with the more deep
biophysical characterization of proteins
that I won't spend so much time talking
about or I won't spend any time in fact
talking about the process scale up or
the downstream processing so at the
beginning of the life of the
biotherapeutic we have the target
pathway discovery phase where we're
trying to understand the biology that
under
that exists in normal biological
processes and that is dysregulated
during the course of disease many of
these methods range from
immunohistochemistry that's often used
in the clinic to be based analysis
method cell lysate arrays western blots
a coulter principal method for studying
cell sizes capillary and micro flora
microfluidic electrophoresis for
understanding size and charge flow
cytometry for studying proteins in cells
and mass spectrometry for studying
protein abundance and modification so
digging more deeply immunohistochemistry
allows one to examine the relative
expression and location of protein and
fixed tissue sections it's important in
the clinical analysis of tissue
specimens for diagnosing disease states
the the phases of cancer it tells you
the proteins relative amount and its
location and gives you an indication of
cell and tissue morphology associated
with diseases or pathology and tissues
but it doesn't tell you charge shape
molecular weight protein purity folded
state isoform the polydispersity are
also known as the size range of the
proteins and so these other pieces of
information will have to be gleaned with
other protein analysis methods this is a
quite old method originally described in
1941 the next phase we have newer
methods including feed based methods in
which many proteins can be examined
simultaneously because these beads are
bar coded with dyes that have a specific
ratio of dyes these ratios of dyes allow
one to to know the identity of the
protein under examination and these
beads are labeled with antibody
that are able to capture the proteins of
interest and then secondary fluorescent
antibodies are used to quantify the
abundance of the or proteins that are
attached to the beads so in theory a
hundred or so proteins can be examined
simultaneously through incubation of
specific beads with with cell lysate in
flow cytometry one is able to examine
proteins in cells or on cells again
using fluorescent for recently labeled
antibodies that bind to specific protein
targets lysate arrays western blots
micro Western arrays and capillary
microfluidic electrophoresis are
different variations on the theme of
applying proteins to different
substrates and then examining their
abundance in either the context of glass
slides or or in gels so the first method
I'll talk about here the cell lysate
microarrays were described in the early
2000s and subsequently evolved a bit in
the mid-2000s and here i'm showing work
from savika a doll and that they
described in nature methods and in this
method you take life eighths from cells
and you can do this with hundreds of
cells treated with small molecules or
therapeutics or growth factors and array
those life states onto a variety of
slides that can then individually be
interrogated with antibodies to
different pan specific meaning measuring
the total abundance of proteins or with
phospho specific or other types of
modification specific antibodies we
subsequently further evolved this method
in 2010 and described a manner in which
protein or microarray methods were used
to array the lysate onto acrylamide gel
that were then subjected to semi dry
electrophoresis and then transferred to
nitrocellulose and probed in 96-well
format with 96 different antibodies and
then we we showed that the signal that
we got from these arrays was linear with
regard to abundance of proteins and that
they were analogous to macro Western
blots but the cool thing with micro
Western arrays is that you could use a
lot less protein than you would normally
use with a Western blot and you could
perform these experiments in a more
automated manner in microtiter format so
in this study we just compared the
response of growth factors it sells a431
cells stimulated with epidermal growth
factor at following either 0 minutes or
60 minutes and we probed for beta-actin
to measure just total protein content in
the green channel and then we followed
the modification state of a series of
tyrosine zon on the epidermal growth
factor receptor itself or downstream
targets of the epidermal growth factor
and then monitor the old changes in the
phosphorylation at different time points
with either large macro Western
traditional Western blots or micro
Western arrays and this is what this
looks like in a 96-well microtiter
format and I show here the
phosphorylation kinetics of s6 ribosomal
protein at the top left which undergoes
very slow increases in modification
after growth factor stimulation versus
the epidermal growth factor receptor
itself below which shows very rapid
phosphorylation kinetics within a minute
of stimulation and then also we probed
all of the wells with beta-actin similar
simply to show that
we had equally arrayed proteins on our
slides and we asked in this study what
the network-wide response of cells was
to stimulation by epidermal growth
factor how do the cancer cells respond
globally to change is also in nutrition
if we simply added more glucose or amino
acids to cells cancer cells how would
their signaling networks respond and how
also would they respond to difference in
growth factor signaling networks there
are different growth factor signaling
levels so this is a very busy slide and
I apologize for that but we were quite
proud at the time at the ability to
attract so many modification states of
important signaling network proteins and
that's what I show on the right of the
chart as all of the different
phosphorylation states that we were
following at the same time and the
important thing to note here is simply
that if you look at the very top of the
chart we show zero nanograms per mil of
EGF added and then we've monitored at 0
15 15 30 and 60 minutes this is simply
adding a new media to cells and when you
look at this you see very few membrane
level proteins at the top that are
changing over the course of one minute
and in fact many of the changes you see
that are depicted in white hot at the
bottom are proteins associated with
insulin akt these are proteins in the
cell that very slowly get up regulated
when the self senses a change in sugar
or amino acid content if you look at the
left part of the chart as we go from two
nanograms to fifty to a hundred to two
hundred you start to see very intense
activation of the growth factor
receptors on the cell surface within one
minute and then they decay but then they
come back at six
and so this is if you look in simply the
one minute panel at the top those were
proteins that underwent maximal
stimulation within one minute then in
the next series at five minutes these
are another series of the map kinases
that are stimulated downstream of the
growth factor receptor itself and that
are responsible for initiating cascades
associated with cell growth so in this
study in summary we quantified 92
phospho sites of different signaling
proteins associated with cancer and cell
growth we probed with different growth
factor levels at six time points we
collected about 24,000 data points and
this was the most data points ever
collected with western blots at the time
of the study in 2010 and this is simply
a zoom-in of the things at one minute
that were maximally stimulated the
receptor tyrosine kinases themselves non
receptor tyrosine kinases at the
membrane as well as tyrosine
phosphatases and adaptor proteins that
turn off the signal so quickly move on
through this slide ultimately we took
the data and wanted to build a bit more
of a higher-level network and so we
worked with researchers at MIT the
Laughlin burger laboratory to use
mathematical inference methods to take
our data and build a causal inference
network that provided insight into the
connectivity of the proteins in the
pathway and could subsequently be used
to try to understand which of the
proteins might be most important in
shutting off the signal such as you
might want to to determine if you were
designing a therapeutic and you wanted
to shut off or find the most sensitive
part
of the network so when you're collecting
protein modification data many times
also want to collect cell phenotypic
data that you can use to relate the
responses of the proteins in the cell to
actual physiological changes in cell
size so I show here the multi size r4e
it uses the so-called Coulter principle
where cells go through an aperture and
the change in resistance as the cell
passes through the aperture is used to
count the cell and it's also used to
determine the sizes of cells and this is
often used in the context of cell
therapy to monitor the changes in cell
size of t-cells are stimulated to
undergo maturation they'll change from
about 10 microns to 30 microns and in
many different physiological contexts
the cell volume will change and the
Coulter principle such as used in the
multi sizer can be used to follow that
when one wants to study proteins on much
larger scales in terms of thousands of
proteins and modification states mass
spectrometry is often used and this is
used in the context of more proteomic
studies and through LCMS liquid
chromatography mass spectrometry
proteins are typically separated based
on hydrophobic interactions such as with
a c18 resin all other methods for
chromatography are gel filtration where
proteins are separated by size ion
exchange where proteins are separated
based on their charge or affinity such
as protein a where a specific protein is
immobilized on a column surfaced and
then used to specifically pull out
proteins based on affinity so getting
back to mass spectrometry typically a
protein is digested and
the peptide mixer is put into a mass
spectrometer and the charge to weight
ratio is examined and then referenced
against a database in order to examine
or identify abundances of proteins or
changes in abundances of proteins and
modification states in the context of
cellular biology so after a specific
target has been identified then
typically a workflow moves forward to
express either the protein targets
themselves for further analysis or to
make antibody-based biotherapeutics
which i show here in yellow and and
typically the cell line is developed and
the help is monitored with something
like the vice l that will through trypan
blue measure percent viability during
the the cell culture process or the meta
flex which measures the changes in in
the glucose and other metabolites
usually there's some centrifugation step
of depending on the process size but at
small scales typically centrifuges use
to pellet cells and then there's some
process of purification via column
chromatography and following or tracking
the expression with with acrylamide gels
and or the functionality using
enzyme-linked immunosorbent assay or
eliza's and then some subsequent
follow-up with mass spectrometry to
confirm the size and the clock
oscillation state of the therapeutic
proteins so let's talk a bit more about
that so as I mentioned in the beginning
phases you're in many cases you may pull
out several clones of different
antibodies or or proteins that have been
modified in different ways to try to
optimize
cell growth conditions and the device l
from beckman coulter is a way that one
can in relatively high throughput
monitor the viability of cells in an
automated way via trypan blue staining
in the meta flex will measure glucose
and several other metabolites that will
give you an indication of the metabolic
state and the health of the cells during
the process and help you to optimize
particular conditions that will give
maximal protein expression so cells are
typically pelleted via low speed
centrifugation and then clarified or the
supernatant clarified with high speed
centrifugation and then often in the
early stages antibodies for example are
purified rapidly the protein a affinity
chromatography and then maybe
subsequently cleaned up via ion exchange
chromatography and then maybe finally
purified via gel permeation or also
known as size-exclusion chromatography
and often during the during the process
the ability of each of these steps to
enrich the purity is often tracked
either by polyacrylamide gels where the
proteins are separated by size and then
examine the either comb a sustaining or
subsequently perhaps by silver or
colloidal coomassie to give a more
sensitive readout Western blots are also
used to confirm that the particular
proteins being examined are the protein
that you are actually trying to follow
and so you would typically generate
antibodies specific to the protein of
interest for the purposes of
immunoblotting functional assays such as
Eliza also known as enzyme-linked
immunosorbent assay
which was developed and first described
actually simultaneously in different
publications my Perlman and in vol back
back before I was born a long time ago
in this method one either attaches to a
microtiter well an antigen of interest
if you are expressing an antibody and
you're looking for function and the the
antibody can either be labeled with
horseradish peroxidase or a floor that
will allow you to track the
functionality of the antibody by its
binding and its color a metric readout
on the on the slide and there are
different ways to perform this either
directly where an antigen is is bound to
a slide and then read out by binding to
an antibody that's that's labeled or
indirectly where a secondary antibody is
actually labeled and then incubated
subsequently with the initial antibody
that you are screening or alternatively
the the sandwich Eliza is performed in
which one antibody is coated on a slide
then an antigen is bound and typically
it with this format you're actually
measuring the functionality of an
antigen and you would take plates that
are coated with a capture antibody for
your antigen and then you would
subsequently add more antibodies to the
antigen of interest in via this sandwich
format you can get much higher
selectivity for the functional antigen
and that you are expressing so lcms is
often used to confirm protein size
integrity modification state and also
the glycosylation of proteins and there
are different flavors of mass
spectrometry depending upon the
situation often matrix assisted laser
desorption ionization also called mall
Lee is used in cases where one wants to
simply characterize very quickly the
integrity the size integrity of a
peptide or protein in this case it's
immobilized onto a surface and I show
here in the middle bottom the a peptide
that's been put on to the surface of a
glove a gold slide and then hit with a
laser and typically these peptides will
pick up a one positive charge under the
conditions and then one simply times the
amount this is all automatically but the
Machine times the amount of time that it
takes to accelerate your peptide that
until it hits a wall photomultiplier
tube and through this process one then
calculates a size to charge ratio which
I depict in the spectra on the top
electrospray also called ESI quadrupole
mass spectrometry is you usually
integrated with inline with some sort of
liquid chromatography and I depict the
process in the bottom right where a hplc
is spraying its contents into it through
a nebulizer into a quadrupole mass
spectrometer and in this case the charge
state of the proteins or peptides is
related to the number of positively
charged amino acids that is arginine and
lysine and it's usually conducted under
very low pH conditions so that all of
the carboxylates are at that point
neutral and then one can if especially
through if you have multiple quadruples
connected in tandem you can fragment the
peptides along the mi backbone and then
read out the amino acid content of the
peptides like I show in the ESI
quadrupole spectra at the top right
where the distance between each of the
peaks is typically
a function of the peptides that are
fragmented along the backbone and used
in an automated way the instruments will
read out the spectra and compare the
spectra to spectra in a database in
order to confirm the identity of the
peptides that you are working with or
like oscillation patterns as well so in
phase three I've talked a bit about the
panning for binders so in an earlier
publication as a postdoc I wished to
uncover the connectivity of proteins and
signaling networks and through this
exercise we cloned and expressed
hundreds of Sark amala g two domains
these are the proteins that recognize
activated growth factor receptors at the
time that i started the postdoc many of
much of the genome had still not yet
been sequenced very well and many of the
proteins in the genome still the
function wasn't clear so we cloned all
of the so-called starcom ology two
domains which have a certain motif that
is predicted it was predicted at the
time to recognize phosphotyrosine motifs
have growth back to receptors and we
wanted to to query the interaction
potential of all of the epidermal growth
factor receptors with all of these
signaling proteins downstream that we
knew were most likely responsible for
the cancer signal of epidermal growth
factor receptor so in this method we use
protein microarrays in this method we
took the collections of the hundreds of
sh2 domains and we arrayed them on to
the surfaces of glass slides and using
this method you're able to screen the
interaction potential of hundreds of
proteins that are
on the slide simultaneously with
hundreds of other fluorescently labeled
proteins or peptides
okay my screen okay here we go so in
this context we actually combined the
previous technology of microscope slide
arrays with the microtiter plate
technology that's often used to to
automate through liquid handling robots
and what I'm showing here on the right
is this merging of protein microarrays
of microtiter technology where each of
the microarrays is contained within the
well of a microtiter plate so that a
mated pipetting robot can then be used
to add different peptides for poor
screening purposes and what I show and
depicting here is a small amount of
fluorescent dye that has been doped into
each of the proteins that we arrayed
onto the slide and when we incubated our
slide with with phosphopeptides that
were derived from the growth factor
receptor then we could start to see that
there were different proteins on the
slide that bound in different affinities
to the peptide that was incubated and
when we used a saturation binding curve
we could fit affinities there were some
peptides that maximize their signal at
very low concentration such as the able
to kinase that bound to this particular
protein of her to also known as herb be
too and the specific phosphorylation
site here was tyrosine 1139 but we could
also characterize if we incubated at
very high concentrations of the peptide
we would see a saturation with lower
affinity proteins such as the breast
cancer anti-estrogen resistance three
protein we had to it the midpoint of
this binding curve was one micromolar
vs.
71 nanomolar for the able to kinase but
because this was all done in an
automated manner in terms of the micro
fluidics or sorry not the micro fluidics
but in terms of the liquid hand length
and in terms of the data extraction via
the image analysis we are able to
quickly characterize the binding
potentials of all 150 of the putative
phospho tyrosine binding proteins in the
in the human genome and we used these
affinity maps to characterize for each
growth factor receptor the epidermal
growth factor receptor also known as rp1
in the top left or b2 in the top right
which is today typically known as her to
her b3 at the bottom left really
recruited the phosphoinositide kinases
really well those were all depicted in
red and then or before which wasn't well
understood at all and I believe today as
it's still a little bit not well
characterized but it's thought to play a
role in in the liver is characterized at
the bottom right so in panning for
binders arrays can be used also the
enzyme-linked immunosorbent assay that I
described before can be used to pan for
binders it's simply with the Eliza
approach one typically is characterizing
96 interactions on a slide versus with
the micro-ray method one can
characterize thousands of interactions
on a slide using thousands of fold less
reagents so finally I will talk about
biophysical and biochemical
characterization methods it's often
times as i showed in these previous few
slides when you're in performing any
particular study you will lean quite
heavily
one particular method or one particular
instrument and it's very important in
order to be a very well-rounded
biochemist biophysicist to have at least
some grounding in a variety of methods
so that when one sees a particular
problem one can quickly identify a
series of potential solutions in order
to move forward in your research so in
the first method I will talk about for
biophysical characterization is light
scattering so the Delta max core is an
example of an instrument that Beckman
Coulter cells which uses both dynamic
and static light scattering to quickly
characterize the molecular weight and
the size distribution and get an
indication of the aggregation state of
proteins in the solution phase without
any label and with light scattering the
correlation of scatter and time will
provide an indication of the sizes of
the proteins in solution so I show at
the top right an example of the large
protein or it could be a protein or it
could be other types of molecules that
the idea is when light is scattering in
time it is quite correlated if the
larger the protein is because it's
moving relatively slowly as the protein
if it is smaller it will actually be
moving much quicker by Brownian motion
and the change in scatter scattering
patterns in time will change much
quicker and using the algorithms of the
instrument it will in the matter of
seconds with a very small amount of
material as few as a few microliters one
can quickly obtain the molecular weight
and the size distribution and the
polydispersity or the range of sizes of
proteins in solution and quickly gain an
understanding of of the quality of
protein that you're working with the
delsym x-pro is an example of an
instrument that uses both
light-scattering as well as a voltage
potential application in order to derive
a charge from protein at the point at
which formulations are developed often
the charge of the proteins and solution
is critical in order for determining
whether or not the proteins will be
stable in solution because of their
repulsion for each other or whether or
not they will tend to coalesce and
agglomerate and fall out of solution in
many types of industries for example in
in water quality they're trying to find
conditions in which the the particles
are neutral so that they will coalesce
and come out of solution during the
water purification process so with a
particular Delta max pro instrument it
has a couple of interesting modules that
are very important in the context of
proteins the first is the so-called
assist module so typically as you're
applying a potential to a solution that
has salt there will be bubbles generated
due to the electric current that will
will generate bubbles and because
bubbles scatter light they interfere
with your ability to collect zeta
potential measurements and with the
assist it actually pressurizes the the
flow cell so that the bubbles don't form
and therefore you can actually measure
the zeta potential or the charge state
of the particles in which in cases where
you typically can't the other
interesting feature of the delsym x-pro
is that it has 32 detectors at different
angles which collect scattering
information in parallel because proteins
are very sensitive if with a standard
zeta potential measuring instrument
that's not been
designed for proteins you will typically
require several minutes in order to
collect enough light scattering data
under the conditions of alternating
electric current before you can gather
enough information with which to derive
a zeta potential whereas with the Delta
maxpro it collects the light scattering
information in parallel for many
detector simultaneously allowing you to
collect the information within a few
seconds and therefore be able to collect
the information before the protein is
destroyed or or degraded due to the
application of the electric potential so
by off during the biophysical and
biochemical characterization process
surface plasmon resonance is also often
used in order to measure in a label-free
manner the binding of and the affinity
actually of an immobilized protein on a
gold surface with proteins that are
flowing in solution and so the first
protein is typically immobilized and
then a second protein small molecule
peptide is flown through a microfluidic
chamber and as more mass binds to the
surface it creates a change in signal
that can be measured by the detector and
what one is typically then examining is
a change from a base level response on
the surface to a maximal level of
response as a function of concentration
of the analyte that's in solution and
through this method one can determine on
rates off rates and steady state binding
profiles
recently a surface acoustic wave
technology has been used to generate
slightly more information than the
surface plasmon resonance method and
through this method if you look at the
binding profiles in the that I show in
the top right what you see our curves
that look very similar to spr however
with the surface acoustic wave
technology using both of the phase of
the acoustic wave on the surface as well
as the amplitude one can examine not
only changes in binding but also changes
in the confirmation of the protein on
the cell surface and again this is this
you can perform kinetic analysis and you
can perform this in a label-free manner
microscale thermophoresis is yet another
way to measure protein interaction
potentials or small molecules peptides
this does use fluorescence so it's it's
there but there are two different
flavors that this can be performed in
one manner intrinsic tryptophan
fluorescence can be used to read out
protein fluorescence and the other you
can attach a flu or to the protein of
interest but in any event with this
method a laser is used to create a
temperature gradient and depending upon
the binding state of your protein the
larger is the slower that it will
migrate along the temperature gradient
and therefore if one performs a
titration series from low low protein to
high protein with a constant amount of
the fluorescently labeled version one
can then quantify a
saturation binding curve as I show in
the bottom right whereas ligand
concentration goes up the the speed at
which the protein is migrating out of
the thermal faradic gradient goes down
so another flavor of this interaction
analysis is bio layer interferometry
with this method the proteins are
actually immobilized on the surface of a
tip and a interference pattern along the
tip is measured as proteins are binding
to the tip and so this tip is typically
dipped into 96 or 384-well plates and
the interference pattern along the tip
is then examined and if you look at the
D sensor gram at the bottom right you'll
see a graph that looks very similar to
spr and the other methods that i've
shown you go from a base state where
nothing is bound to the tip as you begin
to dip into solutions that end up
binding to the surface of your tip with
its immobilized proteins you'll start to
see an increase in the intensity of the
signal in a relationship to the affinity
of your analyte for your proteins this
is again label-free and because it can
be done in 96 or 384-well plate sits
quite high throughput another important
tool is multi angle light scattering so
with multiple angle light scattering
this is typically performed downstream
of size exclusion chromatography as a
way to get an additional corroboration
of the size of a protein so typically
the
the spectrograph or Spectre chromatogram
rather that one takes off of the size
exclusion chromatography is overlaid
with a series of sizing measurements
taken during the online run and in many
cases the protein shape will make it
perform aberrantly on the size exclusion
chromatography and vice versa and the
multiple angles gathering downstream
will allow one to have a second added
level of confidence that the size
readings obtained from the chromatogram
is consistent and in cases where they're
not consistent one can dig deeper to try
to understand what the actual sizes of
the proteins are circular dichroism is a
another method that one can use to
understand the folded states of the
proteins and to compare batches of
proteins if you look in the top right
you see a spectrum of the green and blue
protein from different batches of
proteins that are slightly different and
similarly at the bottom right you see a
natural versus a recombinant
recombinantly expressed version of
protein and they have different spectra
and it's difficult to know exactly what
the difference is but it ultimately is a
different reflection of the ability of
the protein to absorb left and right
polarized light and the alpha helixes
the beta sheets etc given their
asymmetry will absorb right and
left-handed light in different manner
and if you compare batches of proteins
in time you will be able to see that
they're either the same or different
depending on their ability to rotate the
light using circular dichroism
Thermal shift assay is a method that one
can use to determine the stability of
proteins in different conditions and so
using a light cycler or a real-time PCR
instrument with fluorescently labeled
proteins one can apply a temperature
ramp and then measure the fluorescence
under different conditions so I show
that the top right proteins that are
melted under two different conditions
that gives slightly different midpoint
melting temperatures in the bottom right
I show the protein by itself or protein
with a ligand and no protein at all and
you can see that the ligand actually
causes the protein to be more stable and
therefore it takes a higher temperature
before you see the change in
fluorescence so this is a useful useful
for probing formulation conditions and
conditions for which your protein may be
more stable so with isothermal titration
calorimetry one can very rigorously
examine many different biophysical
characteristics of proteins so typically
one will incubate protein with with
another peptide or protein and then
measure the amount of heat that is
generated with small injections of the
peptide or small molecule and as the as
the peptide is injected heat will be
released and this heat and the sample
cell will be compared to a reference
cell and then ultimately with the amount
of heat absorbed one can obtain many
biophysical parameters associated with
the interactions of peptides and small
molecules with your protein of interest
so finally I show analytical
ultracentrifugation this tool is
is extremely rigorous it requires a bit
of a bit more training than some of the
other methods that it's able to answer
many questions associated with the shape
of the protein by itself or with
complexes how the protein behaves in
solution its purity its aggregation
state the association with other
proteins diameter mass the geometry etc
it's an extremely rigorous method and
the optima a you see is an offering from
beckman coulter that that provides this
in summary proteins represent important
therapeutic targets there are a variety
of tools I've just talked about some of
the more commonly used methods and today
in the future we made dive a bit deeper
and I welcome your feedback on some of
the methods that you think would be more
helpful to you and you biological
research obviously periodically
refreshing your protein analysis tool
box in your understanding of each of
these methods is critical for you to be
able to see and identify which tool is
most applicable to solving your for
problem of interest and moving onward
and accelerating the pace of your
discovery with that I thank you and I
welcome any questions thank you very
much thank you dr. Jones for that
informative presentation so it's time
for Q&A if you have a question you'd
like to ask dr. Jones please do so now
just click on the green Q&A button at
the lower left of the presentation
window type your question into the box
it appears on your screen and click on
the send button will answer as many of
your questions as we have time for and
while we're waiting for questions
to come in I would like to once again
thank dr. Jones for his presentation do
you have any final comments for us today
I welcome any questions you have about
either today or in the future about
workflows you have here at beckman
coulter we are constantly reaching out
to folks in the biological community to
try to understand and have a pulse on
these solutions that that you need to
solve your your tools in biomedical
Discovery so I welcome this question
okay well thank you once again and I
would also like to thank our sponsor
beckman coulter life sciences for making
today's educational webcast possible
this webinar has been approved for
continuing educational credits please
click on the CD button at the bottom
left corner and follow the process to
receive your credits before we go I want
to let everyone know that today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through September 2017 you will
receive an email from lab roots letting
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay please show that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us we hope to see you again soon goodbye
all right